et pour en parler nous sommes avec
frédéric jeanjean secrétaire général de
l'union des métiers et des industries de
l'hôtellerie des bouches du rhône merci
d'être avec nous frédéric jeanjean à vos
côtés yves d'amécourt conseiller
régional de nouvelles aquitaine porte
parole national du mouvement de la
ruralité bonsoir à vous aussi
enfin pour le point de vue médical
bertrand legrand aux médecins
généralistes secrétaire général de la
cnm f 59/62 merci d'être avec nous en
direct également bertrand legrand
tout d'abord je m'adresse aux au médecin
que vous êtes l'auteur le grand plutôt
satisfait dans l'ensemble puisque
apparemment rien ne bouge
elle est difficile est fatigués quand
rien ne bouge
lorsqu'on voit c'est surtout que les
contamination diminue mais on garde bien
à l'esprit que on a deux en place des
tests anti j'ai maintenant depuis deux
semaines et que donc le la lutte est
rigide et par email présente une valeur
prédictive négative qui est moins bonne
et que l'on qu'on peut avoir de
relâchement de personnes positives et
donc deux fois positif qui pourrait très
bien expliquer la diminution du nombre
de contaminations ce qu'il va falloir
regarder de près c'est le nombre de
hauts d'entrer à l'hôpital et il y avait
une discordance qui apparaissaient les
vêtements la réponse donc c'est ça le
plus important je pense et 2e eiffage ne
s'avérant nous a pas encore bien précis
mais c'est peut-être antigénique était
un test diagnostique ou un test de
dépistage puisqu'il a utilisé les deux
mots c'est toujours très inquiétant
qu'est-ce qui vous inquiète plus pour
bien pour qu'on comprenne sur ces tests
anti génique oliveira a précisé qu'en
cas de positivité les marges d'erreur
était finalement assez minces compte
amener de la gaieté négativité justement
qu'elle s'était plus importante c'est ça
qui nous inquiète c'est exactement ça
c'est à dire que c'est un test qui a une
très mauvaise
sibilité et donc à partir de ce moment
là si vous le faites chez les patients
qui ont forte prévalence une forte
incidence vous avez maximiser le nombre
de faux négatifs que vous avez relâche
dans la nature est typiquement andy
moudiki on peut tester avec un test anti
des patients symptomatiques de trois à
quatre jours
c'est une erreur fondamentale de cet
antigène ou effet guidé en masse sur des
personnes asymptomatiques
alors que les personnes saint-thomas tic
nécessite un diagnostic par le médecin
donc ça va fort manque de stratégie yves
d'amécourt conseiller régional de novell
aquitaine porte parole également
national du mouvement de la ruralité
vous plutôt rassurés par ces annonces de
jean castex soit au contraire plutôt en
colère très en colère parce qu'en fait
on on gère la france comme si la france
était paris et donc on fait le virus
circule beaucoup plus dans les zones
urbaines que dans les zones rurales et
les zones rurales sont soumises aux
mêmes confinement que les zones urbaines
moi j'espérais que aujourd'hui le
premier ministre allait annoncer que
tous les commerces rouvraient et que par
par contre on serait intransigeant sur
les protocoles de sécurité et de santé
il y a beaucoup de commerces qui sont
aujourd'hui fermées qui réalise 80 % de
leur chiffre d'affaires dans les deux
derniers mois de l'année notamment les
commerces dits non essentiel puisque en
fait ils sont très spécialisés sur les
fêtes de fin d'année est donc
aujourd'hui on les met en grand danger
on est encore en danger ce qui fait
l'armature de nos zones rurales qui sont
les petits commerces les artisans etc et
on met en danger toute la france parce
qu'on n'arrive pas à raisonner
différemment au premier confinement il y
avait eu un couple préfet maire qui
fonctionnait et qui prenait des
décisions localement en fonction des
enjeux locaux et des spécificités
locales c'est ce qui s'était passé
notamment sur les marchés qui avait été
d'abord fermé puis ré ouvert et en
fonction des saisons et des des lieux et
là vraiment on raisonne comme si la
france était paris on se bouscule dans
le métro et on interdit tout en france
opuscule dans les commerces et dans les
rues commerçantes de paris on ferme tous
les commerces en france
va y revenir évidemment il veut d'amico
je vous propose justement d'écouter jean
castex sur la question des commerces
était une des questions les plus
attendus évidemment aujourd'hui en
france notamment pour les commerçants
qui jouent leur survie du côté des
premières mesures d'allégement pourrait
intervenir à compter du 1er décembre
mais elle serait strictement limitée au
commerce que nous avons dû fermer à
partir du confinement et leur
réouverture ne pourrait s'envisager que
sur la base d'un protocole renforcé
frédéric jeanjean vous vous représentez
justement l'union des métiers des
industries de l'hôtellerie des bouches
du rhône même colère que yves d'amécourt
il ya quand même une lueur d'espoir jean
castets nous parle du 1er décembre sous
couvert de restrictions importantes
il a quand même été dit qu'il était hors
de question inenvisageable les
restaurants les bars et des salles de
sport puisse rouvrir
c'est quand même été bien entendu je
pense que d'une manière globale il faut
se poser de vraies questions
on nie pas la pandémie on nie pas la
problématique ce qui pose problème c'est
la gestion de la pandémie et on a vu
qu'il ya eu une première étape premier
confinement et depuis
eh bien on se rendre compte que en dépit
de tout ce que le gouvernement a pu
raconter dire proposer contredire parce
qu'il ya eu beaucoup de contradictions
aussi au début et bien le virus est
encore là et se développe de plus en
plus donc ce qui pose de bonnes problème
je pense que c'est la méthode nous avons
essayé de proposer des procédures au
gouvernement lorsqu'on est venu fermer
marseille
ils ont proposé un protocole sanitaire
renforcée monsieur verrons a refusé de
nous adresser la parole
finalement ce protocole a été utilisé
pour toute la france je pense que ce qui
pose un problème à l'heure actuelle un
très gros problème c'est ce gouvernement
et sa méthode
c'est le discours de la méthode 10
annoncée des aides je peux vous en
parler de ces aides
ils sont venus annoncer à marseille à la
fin du mois de septembre début du mois
d'octobre pour l'instant on n'a pas vu
la queue d'un radis et les radis nous on
les connaît on cuisine on les travaille
souvent donc je peux vous dire que à
l'heure actuelle il ya un mécontentement
très fort nous avons fait tout ce que
nous pouvions pour être force de
proposition nous ne pouvons plus être
entendu
eh bien nous allons trouver tantôt
moyenne pour nous faire entendre à
partir de maintenant bertrand legrand
est ce que vous comprenez cette colère
de nos amis restaurateurs bar restaurant
les empêche d'ouvrir ils nous ont fait
des efforts monsieur jean gens nous
disaient voilà encore de plus en plus
finalement deux cas de contamination
alors qu'on a pris des mesures de plus
en plus strictes qu'est ce que vous en
pensez vous en tant que médecin c'est
très difficile parce que je pense qu'ils
ont vraiment fortement souffert et de
voir que on dit shi par défaut de bonnes
stratégies et par des foules de steve de
tactique les rend particulièrement en
colère et cette colère moi je
l'entendais prendre jusqu'à l'heure pas
question de fermer ses restaurants et
ses bars pour nous ces longues heures et
selon vous est-ce que c'est là qu'on se
contaminent le plus fait ce qu'elle ait
digéré par contre malheureusement si en
france on n'a pas été capables de les
fusiller landreau avons terminé aux
états unis l'ont fait et on voit bien
que malheureusement les bars des
restaurants les discothèques les salles
de sport sont des environs se contenait
énormément avec c'est vraiment un décès
si nos gars rythmique donc
malheureusement cette fois mille fois
après 2000 x 3000 cc3c croyable et juste
pour vous dire la 7e ligne après la
religion va après l'office religieux
c'est les qualités de médecine générale
on peut jauger vous dire que je
comprends très bien et je comprends très
bien que les protocoles renforcées sont
nécessaires malheureusement on est sur
une zone contient une fréquence
importante de la maladie ces endroits là
ce sont les endroits où on a le plus de
chances d'être compté les médias un
espoir artistes dans cette étude il a
démontré que si on diminue le nombre de
personnes présentes dans ses restaurants
on arrive à elle aussi exponentiellement
à diminuer la contamination
mais encore une fois dans les collèges
c'est pourquoi la stratégie est si
mauvaise et pourquoi la contamination se
répand alors qu'on est maintenant les
tests des masques c'est simplement parce
qu'on n'arrive pas à l'isoler positif on
isole pas déposé
différents relâche des faux négatifs
c'est incroyable mais c'est la
conséquence première c'est qu'on est
obligé sperme et des lieux qui sont des
de contestation malgré tous les efforts
qu'ils ont cure ils veulent aller quand
je vous voyez opiné du chef
le principal problème est celui là pour
vous aussi la question des tests dans
notre pays il ya deux problèmes le
problème que vient d'exprimer le docteur
c'est comment est-ce qu'on repère les
positif comment est ce qu on les isole
et le deuxième problème c'est l'armement
de l'hôpital pour pouvoir accueillir les
personnes qui ont besoin d'être en
réanimation au mois de juillet le
président on a un public promettait qui
aurait 12 mille lits et les legends
formée pour la deuxième vague
en fait je pense qu'il ne croyait pas
sur une deuxième vague puisque
aujourd'hui on est assimilé lit et donc
on n'est pas aux douze mille lits promis
et donc aujourd'hui on est en train
d'arrêter l'économie d'un pays parce
qu'on n'a pas su armée l'hôpital parce
qu'on a pas su faire des des
partenariats avec les cliniques privées
qui était prête à rentrer dans la danse
et qui en fait ont été boudées au début
et donc voilà on n'a pas à armer nos
hôpitaux et le président a déclaré la
guerre est réuni son conseil de décence
mais en fait il n'a pas pris les mesures
qu'on attendait qu'ils prennent donc
mauvaise détection des positifs et nos
armes nos armements des hôpitaux et
c'est nous qui trinquons partout sur
tout le territoire
à propos d'hôpitaux bertrand legrand
jean castex amiens incertain voire
enthousiasmés à saluer à féliciter
les soignants ça ne vous a pas échappé
défaut peut-être d'augmenter les moyens
concrets à l'hôpital ce que je regrette
c'est que aujourd'hui on est fondée une
théorie qui est de rémunérer pour la
réalisation de tests antigénique qui
sont pas bons et de ne pas rémunérer les
tests pcr
quand ils sont réalisés par les médecins
c'est complètement stupide
on est en train de biaiser la main du
préleveur par un problème financier
c'est le même acte l'un on utilise un
test pour quelqu'un qui est très
symptomatique nôtre où un test pour des
personnes qui sont symptomatiques
le paiement doit être exactement le même
pour le même acte et pour tous les
prévenus et après l'acte intellectuelle
de l'analyse et de l' isolement a une
valeur qu'il est forcément supérieurs
aux prélèvements qui est plus rapide
c'était l'heure de stratégie c'est un
pousse au crime et on le payera très
cher dans six semaines
alors il ya eu quelques annonces
peut-être réconfortante sur le point de
vue économique on verra ça avec frédéric
jeanjean dans quelques instants mais
avant je voudrais vous faire justement
écouter bruno le maire concernant les
loyers des commerces
nous mettrons en place dans le budget
un crédit d'impôt de 50% du montant du
loyer abandonné pour tous les bailleurs
qui renonce au loyer du mois de novembre
pour toutes les entreprises qui ont
jusqu'à 250 salariés et qui sont fermés
et j'invite à nouveau par conséquent
tous les bailleurs qui ont signé cet
accord à renoncer à leur loyer du mois
de novembre pour tous les commerces
jusqu'à 250 salariés qui sont fermés un
petit bailleur par exemple qui pour
compléter sa retraite dispose d'un loyer
de 600 euros touchera 300 euros de
crédit d'impôt est locataire lui du coup
n'aura pas à payer son loyer du mois de
novembre cela l'aidera à passer cette
période difficile
après frédéric jeanjean ça c'était
vraiment aussi l'une des requêtes enfin
l'un des soucis et principaux des
commerçants le loyer
et charges qui se poursuivent la
trésorerie est ce que quand même c'est
de manière un petit peu a été atténué la
souffrance des commerçants selon vous je
pense qu'il faut revenir sur la question
de la méthode
quand nous avons parlé des loyers nous
avions mis à spécifier qu'il y avait
trois types de loyer il ya le loyer qui
est dû aux pouvoirs publics et
collectivités territoriales létale
et là on demandait l'abandon total il ya
ensuite des grandes foncières qui
établit un loyer à partir d'un
prévisionnel est là il faut revoir le
prévisionnel la baisse et ensuite vous
allez particuliers qui louent un bien
immobilier
et là on demandait à ce que ce soit à
leurs prêts qu'on arrive et qu'on leur
enlève de leurs impôts
un retraité qui arrive dans c'est l'une
des rares sources de revenus
vous pouvez pas lui dire on va vous
enlevez la moitié il faut impérativement
qu'on puisse lui dire vous ne vous
n'allez pas souffrir
il y en a pas tant que ça des
propriétaires privés qui les
particuliers qui sont qui sont bailleurs
donc il y a là encore une question de
méthode on essaie de faire du global la
globalisation
tout à l'heure on parlait d'un général
qui partait à l'armée c'est un général
d'opérette ou sebha dingue et quan on va
se retrouver comme la halle à sedan
voilà c'est ce qui nous attend et ça va
être une catastrophe économique une
catastrophe sanitaire une catastrophe
sociale
sachez qu'à l'heure actuelle dans les
bouches-du-rhône où nous en sommes à
notre troisième confinement nous en
sommes à mettre en place des procédures
pour la prévention des suicides chez les
chefs d'entreprise pour les artisans les
tpe les pme et je tiens à rappeler
encore une fois je l' ai déjà dit à
plusieurs reprises que le printemps
arabe en tunisie a démarré avec un
commerçant qui c'est arrivé qui s'est
immolé si jamais il ya un dérapage on ne
pourra plus rien maîtriser et le
gouvernement là ne pourra pas dire fait
dire à qui savaient pas évidemment comme
d'habitude mais par contre il devra
faire face à ses responsabilités
effectivement chacun ce texte qui a
indiqué que l'activité économique
pourrait baisser de 12% mois de novembre
mais précise-t-il trois fois moins qu'au
printemps dernier elisabeth bord de la
mini
elle a évoqué les droits à l'assurance
chômage était une information importante
aussi ce soir écouter comme l'a annoncé
le premier ministre
nous allons donc prolongé de la durée du
confinement les droits à l'assurance
chômage pour les chômeurs arrivant en
fin de droit par exemple un demandeur
d'emploi dont les droits auraient dû
s'éteindre fin novembre continuera à
toucher son allocation chômage au mois
de décembre il à mes cours ça c'est
quand même une bonne nouvelle vous
parlez des états unis tout à l'heure on
sait qu'il ya beaucoup moins de
protection sociale qui jettent souvent
beaucoup de gens dans la rue il y a au
moins ça en france oui mais il faut
ouvrir ça pour tous les gens dont on
vient de parler donc les indépendants
les commerçants les artisans les auto
entrepreneurs tous ceux dont l'activité
est stoppé et qui eux n'ont pas le droit
qui n'ont pas accès à l'assurance
chômage et donc un geste fort serait
était d'ouvrir le droit à l'assurance
chômage pour tous les gens qu'on empêche
de travailler aujourd'hui et ça c'est
pas proposé et donc c'est quand même
terrible qui se passe on est en train de
tuer l'économie et on est en train de
penser que la seule vie qui compte c'est
la vie biologique alors la vie sociale
la vie professionnelle la vie
spirituelle toutes ces villas sont
bafoués martyrisée dans la vie c'est pas
simplement de manger de boire de rester
chez soi c'est bien plus que ça la vie
et donc il va falloir quand même que ce
gouvernement raisonne différemment
écoute un petit peu plus nos philosophes
comme andré comte sponville qui depuis
trois semaines plaide sur les plateaux
de télévision pour qu'on reconnaisse les
vies de tout de tout le monde fasse ça
ne sert à rien de annoncé qu'il ya un an
un malade de de plus toutes les 30
secondes c'est quoi ce discours ce qui
nous intéresse c'est de savoir si les
malades peuvent être prises en charge
c'est pas savoir s'il ya un malade de
plus toutes les 30 secondes
la vérité c'est que la moyenne d'âge des
gens qui meurent du coc vide et 81 ans
que l'âge médian est de 84 ans et
qu'aujourd'hui on est en train
d'empêcher des enfants d'aller à l'école
qu'on est en train d'empêcher des
étudiants d'étudier qu'on est en train
d'empêcher des entrepreneurs de 1heure
d'entreprendre des commerçants de vendre
des artisans de travailler enfin tout ça
est hallucinant il ya soixante dix mille
morts du tabagisme en france chaque
année
est ce qu'on a mis en place
une telle armada de mesure complètement
incohérente pour lutter contre le
tabagisme
enfin si vraiment il ya un enjeu
sanitaire mais il faut passer le paquet
de cigarettes à 60 euros
et puis il faut interdire le tabac il
faut verbaliser les gens qui fument
enfin henry dans quel pays c'est
incroyable ce qui se passe dans notre
pays c'est incroyable bertrand legrand
quand vous entendez cet argumentaire
parce que c'est vrai que beaucoup de
personnes il faut être honnête pense
cela d'ailleurs on va regarder peut-être
un petit sondage 60% des sondés ont déjà
30 presser au moins une fois les règles
du confinement sedan thuy % d'entre eux
disent avoir un mauvais moral 38% disent
avoir des troubles du sommeil
c'est vrai que c'est très grave cette
pandémie les chiffres voilà sont
impressionnants est ce que cela vaut
qu'on arrête un pays entier frédéric
jeanjean parler d'éventuels suicide ça
arrivera peut-être on le souhaite pas
mais enfin quelle est l'opinion du
médecin là dessus parce que ça
correspond à la pensée beaucoup fraude
de français aussi oui les français sont
extrêmement en colère
et moi je le comprends je le comprends
parce que cette suggestion est un des
chèques à la fois de la stratégie met en
place à la fin de la tactique était de
moment où la stratégie est forcé de
regarder que
régulièrement sur notre antenne et
malheureusement chaque fois on prévient
avance qu' on va d'échec en échec et
derrière la dénonciation aujourd'hui des
problématiques souhaite et antigénique
vous verrez que la prochaine fois on
nous en avons nous en mettra une
descente sans plus
donc les gens n'en peuvent plus il faut
commencer par corriger nos erreurs avant
de l'amplifier le les mesures
restrictives pour des gens qui ne sont
pas malades
on n'est même pas capable en france d'
isoler correctement les gens malades
peut-être que la privation de liberté et
pour les gens qui sont malades
alors c'est avec vous mais je suis
désolé d'avoir abandonné après avoir
isolé les gens avec leurs familles et
donc aujourd'hui il faut isoler le mal
isolé la famille du malade parce qu'on
va pas mettre les gens dans des hôtels
ou jeune c'était le truc qui lui est la
réalité des choses ces caravanes et
valade avec céline moi quand je me suis
en était tombé malade le suivait avec
m'appelle comme ça
frédéric jeanjean pour vous ces deux
camps finalement on irait consignables
socialement qui privilégie au maximum la
santé ce que fait aujourd'hui le
gouvernement et ceux qui voudraient
privilégiés comme on le voit donald
trump aux états unis finalement
l'économie
je pense pas qu'on puisse opposer les
deux ce qu'il faut c'est essayer de
raisonner et de raisonner sainement ce
qui ne semble pas le cas
c'est à dire que le gouvernement fait
des annonces qu'ils aillent au bout des
choses qu'ils écoutent qu'il concerne
pas simplement concertée dans un salon
avec trois ou quatre personnes
qu'il essaye de voir il ya des prêts
faits sur le territoire il ya des élus
locaux
ils peuvent faire les remonter on peut
voir région à région
et quand on s'engage comme ça a été le
cas la part de monsieur grise et le 7
octobre à marseille à nous dire que nous
aurions des 10000 euros par mois et que
pour l'instant on se rend compte qu'on
nous rappelle les procédures pour qu'on
puisse être indemnisé et qu'on ne verra
ça qu'à partir de la fin du mois de
novembre
c'est se de la gueule du monde
alors ils s'en lavent et leurs
statistiques avec la communication c'est
très bien qu'ils s'amusent entre eux
mais ils sont en train de mettre le pays
cul par dessus tête quant à monsieur
verra quand on le sollicite pour lui
proposer le protocole sanitaire
renforcée qui va être appliqué par la
suite dans tout le territoire
qu'il refuse nous adresser la parole
parce qu'il est qu une boursouflure dgo
et bien ça c'est insupportable de ces
gens là soient en situation de prendre
les décisions
ma dernière question elle concerne
l'école puisque c'était attendu par
beaucoup de syndicats qui ont fait une
grève
avant-hier d'ailleurs pour demander
l'extension des mesures de restrictions
renforcées aux collèges et aux primaires
bertrand legrand vous auriez souhaité ça
c'était souhaitable pour vous finalement
le miz blanc caire ne bouge pas les
choses les lycées sont toujours en force
et en termes de mesures mais pas les
collèges les primaires on est toujours
la même chose
au début on pensait que les enfants
étaient plus content et je voulais me
supplémentaires sur la base de ce que je
pu voir dans quelle est dans mon cabinet
puis on s'est rendu compte que les six
étaient bien contents et qu'elle est
bien des clauses store qui se formaient
dans les airs et dans les écoles et dans
les collèges et on revient que les
clusters le meilleur voyage d'ego baisse
est extrêmement simple ces beignets et
on est toujours dans ce délit les lions
ont peur de parler glace parce que on ne
pas voir les costauds on va de france ça
peut marcher comme ça c'est pas aussi
merci à tous les trois frédéric jeanjean
yves d'amécourt et bertrand legrand
d'avoir été avec nous en réaction
banques aux annonces ou non annonce
d'ailleurs de jean castex merci à vous